courtroom drama unfolding in Utah
actress Gwyneth Paltrow took the witness
stand Friday in the Civil Trial over a
ski Collision Paul's showing the
plaintiff have been locked in legal
battles for seven years since their
Collision on a beginner slope he claims
that she recklessly crashed into him and
caused several serious injuries she
insists he's at fault
Carter Evans has more
we'd like to call Gwyneth Paltrow thank
you oscar-winning actress Gwyneth
Paltrow was grilled on the stand I
didn't engage in Risky Behavior I
wouldn't with my children there or
without my children there she's facing a
three hundred thousand dollar lawsuit
after a collision on the slopes while
skiing with her family in Park City Utah
I can still watch my children ski and be
skied directly into my back by someone
but 76 year old retired optometrist
Terry Sanderson says Paltrow slammed
into him while skiing back in 2016
causing life-altering injuries Gwyneth
Paltrow's neglect her choices and her
conscious disregard for other people on
the mountain all combined together to
cause Terry Sanderson to Suffer Well who
ran into who and he says did you or you
ran into me and Gwen it's like no you
ran square right into me shortly after
the Collision Sanderson sent this email
to his daughter saying I'm famous at
what cost and there was a discussion
about the incident being caught on a
GoPro camera it's nowhere to be found
you skied directly into my effing back
and he said oh sorry sorry I'm sorry
Paltrow's counter suing for one dollar
and legal fees I think both parties are
looking for some sort of personal
Vindication uh it's clearly not about
the money it's costing far more to
litigate this case than is actually at
stake Gwyneth Paltrow's two kids apple
and Moses were with her at the time of
the accident apparently Moses was right
next to her he was nine years old at the
time and he could be called to testify
when the trial resumes next week for CBS
Saturday morning I'm Carter Evans in Los
Angeles